foreign
YouTube channel in today's video we're
going to talk about Google tag manager
now we're going to talk about what are
tags what is Google tag manager how do
you use it I'll be giving a short demo
of it and I will close with some tips as
usual I am our campman I'm your digital
navigator for this video and if you
liked the video click the like button
and if you want to subscribe to our
Channel click the Subscribe button down
below but before we start I want to
share something with you first so simply
learn has a new program a new
certificate for digital marketing
together with Purdue with meta and it
takes you through all the courses and
all the topics of digital marketing that
are relevant for you it sets you up for
Facebook's digital marketing exam where
you learn everything about Facebook
advertising managing your Facebook page
so it's a very you useful program that I
can highly recommend you you sign up for
so click on the link to the website
you'll find a link in the description of
the video below and check it out have a
look we can highly recommend this course
to you so without further Ado let's get
started the famous Google tag manager
you might have heard of it before you
might be asking yourself right now what
is the heck is Google tag manager well
let me tell you it's a tool that will
make your life as a marketeer a lot
easier it's a free tool from Google that
lets you manage and deploy marketing and
analytics tags or Snippets of codes on
your website or on your mobile app
without having to edit this code those
tags trigger events like tracking all
user interaction on your website it's
like having a personal assistant to help
you with the technical stuff so you can
focus on the create creative side of
things the tool was introduced by Google
in 2012 and since then it has become one
of the most widely used tag Management
systems online you might be wondering
now what are the texts don't worry about
it we'll cover that in the next slide
but in short Google tag manager helps
you simplify the process of managing
tags and tracking using user behavior on
your website
it's user friendly and efficient tool
and it saves you a lot of time plus who
doesn't like a free tool that makes your
life easier but before we dive into the
world of Google tag manager yeah let's
talk a bit more about what the this
video will cover so in this session
we'll cover a variety of topics related
to Google tag manager first we'll
discuss what Google texts are and how
they work we'll then move on to what
Google tag manager is and how it can
help you manage your website tags more
efficiently then we'll talk about why
you need Google tag manager we'll
compare Google tag manager with Google
analytics and we'll discuss the benefits
of using Google tag manager over other
tag Management Solutions we'll then go
over how to set up Google tag manager
step by step I'll give you a short demo
so we'll make sure you have all the
information
that you need to be successful with
Google tag manager and finally I'll give
you some tips and tricks for using
Google tag manager more efficiently from
naming conventions to Version Control
we'll share some of the best practices
that can save you tons of time and
headaches in the long run
and then by the end of this video you
should have a solid understanding of
Google fact manager and how it can
benefit you and your website so before
we dive into the specifics of the
platform let's take a moment to discuss
Google Tags so what are they well simply
put their Snippets of code that allows
you to track various actions and data on
your website they're like little spies
they keep an eye on what your visitors
are doing and they report it back to you
for example you can use Google Tags to
track when someone clicks on a specific
button on your website or how long they
stay on a particular page or even if
they abandon their shopping cart
then this information can be used to
improve your website and your marketing
efforts so without tax you'll be Flying
Blind when it comes to understanding how
people are interacting with your website
but with Google Tags you'll have a
wealth of information and data at your
fingertips
so let's then move on to Google tag
manager Google tags are codes of snippet
created by Google tags that are designed
to work with various Google tools like
analytics like Google ads they allow you
to track user interactions such as
clicks page views and many more type of
an interactions they're code Snippets
that are small pieces of code that you
can add to your website to track user
behavior and gather important data so
the beauty of these tags is that you
don't need to be a coding expert to use
them with Google tag manager you can
easily add modify and remove those tags
without having to touch the code on your
website you don't have to be a developer
to do this so if you're a marketeer or a
data analyst or just someone who is
interested in understanding how people
interact with your website these little
Snappers of code can provide a lot of
valuable insights but make sure you're
using them correctly and always test
your tags before publishing them to your
live website Google tags are not only
Snippets of code but they are also used
for tracking purposes they allow you to
track specific events on your websites
like clicks on a button or form
submissions or video plays you can also
track how users interact with your
website like how long they stay on the
page what pages they visit how deep do
they scroll on the page and by tracking
this user Behavior you can gain
fantastic insights in how users engage
with your website and this can help you
in optimizing your website as well to
improve the user experience for example
if you notice that many people are
abandoning the shopping cart you can use
Google Tags to track the point where
they leave the card and adjust your
website design or Mark marketing
strategy accordingly Google Tags a lot
of very important function of them is
that you can use them for remarketing
which means that you can Target users
who have already interacted with your
website with a personalized ads this can
help increase conversions and customer
retention so when somebody visits your
website it will trigger the tag yep and
then it will activate the ad in Google
ads or in Facebook ads and then people
will that that person that visited your
website will then receive and
personalized ads so in short Google text
they do not only provide important data
on user Behavior but can also you can
use it to use the data to improve your
website and improve your marketing
efforts so very important in Google tag
manager are also the containers yes so
there are you use containers in Google
tag manager so what are containers think
of them as the holding area for your tag
you can create multiple containers for
different website sections or even for
individual Pages yeah now let's dive a
bit deeper into the most huge tags in
Google tag manager the first one is the
Google analytics tag yeah which is used
to track the website traffic and
behavior so when you want to track your
websites and analytics by Google you
have to add a tag on every page of your
website
and when people visit that page that
will trigger Google analytics that it
will track that interaction on your
website
not a very popular tank is the Facebook
pixel tag which helps track convergence
from Facebook ads the third tag that's
commonly used is the AdWords conversion
tracking tag which is used to track
conversions from Google AdWords
campaigns and fourth stage for instance
the hot jar tag which is used for
website heat mapping and user Behavior
Analysis finally there is also the
Google optimization tag which is used
for a b testing and for personalization
these are just a few of the many tags
available in Google tag manager but
they're definitely the most commonly
used ones so now that you know what
containers are in the most used tags in
Google tag manager you should be able to
start creating your own tags and your
own containers so let's get into the
details here let's look at how you
manage your tags using Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is a
powerful tool that allows you to to
manage all your website tags in one
place without having to code anything on
your website you don't have to get into
the code of your website you don't have
to add any code for you on your website
Google tag manager will do that gone are
those days that you have to ask your
developer to add tracking codes to your
website or landing pages with Google tag
manager you can do it yourself you can
easily add modify and deploy tags to
your website without any technical
knowledge so with Google tag manager or
GTM as people call it you can manage
tags for all kinds of purposes such as
tracking remarketing conversion tracking
and you can also create triggers that
determine when and where the tags are
fired on your website so GTM is made to
make your life easier and with the help
of this tool you'll be able to
streamline your digital marketing
efforts when it comes to tracking your
website performance and make marketing
data traffic and make data driven
decisions to help grow your business so
let's dive in and explore the world of
Google tag manager so Google tag manager
is like a superhero it saves the day and
it helps you manage all the tags on your
website it's free yeah it's from Google
and it helps you simplify that process
of adding and managing multiple tracking
tags and we've gone through those tags
yeah like Google analytics Facebook
analytics and you don't need a developer
to get involved
the beauty about GTM is that it provides
an intuitive interface that lets you set
up test and deploy the tags quickly so
you can focus on optimizing your website
without having to worry about managing
those code Snippets with GTM you can
also easily update your tags easy add
new ones or remove old ones all in one
central location
yeah so think of GTM of the conductor of
a well orchestrated band it brings all
your tracking tags together and ensures
they play in harmony so you can hear a
beautiful Melody of Data Insights
so summing up Google tag manager is like
having a personal assistant for your
website taking care of all the tracking
tags so you can focus on what really
matters and that is making your website
look awesome and work awesome for you
one of the biggest benefits of Google
tag manager's interface is that it
allows you to manage all your tags in
one place
yeah so that means no more searching
through the lines of code to find that
one tag that causes the issue on your
site with GTM you can just easily add
edit or remove tags
but there's more the GTM interface also
offers a preview mode so you can test
your tags before they go live yeah and
let's not forget about the custom
variables and the triggers that you can
use with GTM you can set up variables to
track specific user behavior and create
triggers to fire tags based on those
actions it's like having your own spy
Network tracking every move your users
make on your website yeah so Google
stack manager interface is like having a
trusty sidekick that takes care of all
your tagging needs
easy to use it offers a preview mode and
allows you to create custom variables
and triggers so then why do I need
Google tag manager well let's face it
websites today are loaded with all kind
of tags from tracking codes to
conversion pickles and it can be a
hassle to manage all of those yet not to
mention the headache you have to go
through and manage to wait for your web
developer to make even the slightest
this is where Google tag manager comes
in to save your day yeah with Google tag
manager you have complete control over
all your tags without having to rely on
a developer it also allows you to easily
set up the tracking and conversion
events plus it makes it easy to test and
debug your tests before Dogo day go live
yep and let's not forget about time
saving benefits of GTM yeah with
everything in one place you can stream
your online your workflow and get more
done in last time so adding tracking
codes as we know can be a headache yep
certainly
you don't want those headaches and
that's why Google tag manager comes in
it provides these user-friendly
interface to easily manage all of your
tracking codes in one place not only
does it make managing those codes easier
but it also saves time and eliminates
the need for technical expertise you
don't have to be a computer wizard to
use Google tag manager with it you can
easily add edit and remove tracking
codes with just a few clicks plus it
allows for greater customization and
flexibility and that will give you
better insights and therefore better
decision making so why do we need Google
tag manager to simplify Our Lives Save
times and make managing tracking codes a
lot easier
trust me once you start using it you
won't know how you ever lived without it
managing tags as I said clearly it can
be like juggling to keep track of all
the different balls and make sure that
they don't drop now with Google tag
manager it's like having an assistant
who's an expert juggler
without it as I told you before it can
be a real headache you have to go into
the code of each individual page and add
or remove those tags manually and if you
have a lot of text I tell you that could
be a lot of code that you have to shift
through
but again with GTM you can manage all
your tags in one place and easily add or
remove them without having to touch the
code on your website
so if you have multiple tags that you
need to keep track of on your website
GTM is a must it simplifies the process
and helps ensure that your tags are
implemented correctly and efficiently
and thereby you have more time to work
on those things that really matter
so another key benefit is how easy it
makes updating those tags on your
website again you don't rely on
developers to add and remove tracking
codes you don't lose time with it you
have full control over all your tags
allowing you to add them quickly modify
or remove them whenever you need to
think of it like a magic wand for your
website's tracking no more waiting for
someone else to do it for you you're in
the driver's seat now plus with the
intuitive interface of GTM it's so easy
to do even if you're not a coding with
it
so you can easily fix errors and typos
in your text without having to wait for
the developer to do this it's like
having a safety net to your website's
tracking ensuring that your data is
always accurate and up-to-date
yes so if you want to take control of
your website's tracking then Google
manager is Google tag manager is
absolutely a must another reason why you
need Google tech manager is that it
allows you to easily manage multiple
tags from different sources like Google
analytics like AdWords and even
third-party tags so you no longer have
to to worry about missing out on
valuable data because you can now keep
track of all those different tracking
codes
but it also allows you to prioritize and
organize those tags so you can ensure
that the most important ones are firing
correctly and in the right area order
and with the built-in error checking and
debugging tools and we'll talk about
that later you can quickly identify and
fix issues as soon as they come up
so with Google tag manager you can make
updates to your text without having to
touch the code so that gives you so much
extra time you win a lot of time where
you can focus on those things that
really matter so let's talk about the
difference between Google tag manager
and Google analytics yes Google
analytics is a powerful tool that helps
you analyze your website's traffic the
user Behavior and the performance of
your website it's like that agent that
gathers information on your website
visitors on the other hand Google tag
manager is like the secret agent's
assistant
it helps manage and deploy all the
tracking codes or tags on your website
think of it like a personal assistant
who takes care of all the tedious tasks
so the main agent Google analytics in
this case can focus on the important
stuff
well both tools are important to your
website success they do serve different
purposes
Google analytics gives you insight into
your website's performance while GTM
helps you manage and organize the
tracking codes that feed into Google
analytics in other words Google
analytics is like the captain of the
ship navigating the orders while GTM is
the Navigator who helps guide to Captain
and make sure everything is running
smoothly
so whether you're an analytics expert or
an office knowing the difference between
these two tools will help you better
understand how to optimize your
website's performance yeah so let me
explain this in a bit more detail
yeah so if you're using Google analytics
you know what it means when you feel
like you're drowning in data
well that's because GA is a very
powerful Analytics tool but it doesn't
come with any tag management
capabilities and that's where GTM comes
in GTM and Google analytics may seem
similar at first but they serve
different purposes
GA helps you track and analyze your
website traffic while GTM helps you
manage tracking your tags
it's like GA is the map that tells you
where you are and GTM is the compass
that helps you navigate to where you
want to go
without GTM you have to manually add a
tracking tags to your website code every
time you want to track a new event or
behavior that's like trying to build a
car with your bare hands instead of
using tools GTM simplifies the process
by letting you add and manage tags
through a user-friendly interface
so while GA is great for analyzing data
it is not equipped to handle tag
management that's why GTM is a necessary
tool for any website owner or marketeer
looking to streamline their tracking
efforts now that we understand the basic
differences between GTM and Google
analytics let's talk about one of the
most important aspects of these tools
data collection
Google analytics is primarily designed
to collect and analyze website traffic
data it helps you understand things like
where your visitors are coming from
which pages are most popular and how
long people are spending on your site
on the other hand GTM is focused on
collecting data about specific actions
or events on your website like a forms
admission or a button click it allows
you to track these interactions and
create custom tags that trigger based on
the data collected
think of it this way if Google analytics
is a map of the traffic flow on your
website GTM is the traffic light that
helps you control and manage that flow
by using GTM to manage your tags and
tracking you can get more granular
insights into behavior of your users and
optimize your website accordingly and
since GTM is designed to work seamlessly
with Google analytics you can easily
combine the insights from both tools to
get a complete picture of your website's
performance yep so whether you're a
marketeer or a developer using both GTM
and Google analytics can help you make
data-driven decisions and improve your
website's overall effectiveness so
another important difference is the way
the tools report on the data and how
they visualize the data
yes so you'll be happy to know that
Google analytics of course has some very
Nifty visualization tools
with Google analytics you can create
custom dashboards and reports that show
your website data in all sorts of fancy
ways if you want a graph that shows the
number of people who visited your
website from a specific country Google
analytics can do that if you want to do
in a pie chart that shows the breakdown
of traffic sources Google analytics can
do that but Google tag manager doesn't
offer any visualization tools what it
does offer is the ability to collect
data and send it to Google analytics
where you can then turn it in charts and
graphs while GTM may not have the eye
candy that GA has it has to be how it is
to behind the scenes Workhorse that
makes it all possible
think of GTM as the stage crew of a
Broadway show they may not be in the
spotlight but without them the whole
production falls apart so when it comes
to user friendliness GTM and Google
analytics couldn't be more different
GTM is like your fun easy going friend
who's always up for a good time while GA
is like your uptight neighbor who
complains about your music being too
loud
gtm's interface is designed with the
user in mind making it easy to navigate
and understand you don't need to be a
coding genius to use it in fact you
don't even need to know how to code it
all plus its drag and drop functionality
makes adding and managing tags a breeze
now on the other hand GA is a bit of a
dinosaur it's a bit more complex and it
can take time getting used to it's like
trying to assemble a piece of furniture
without any instructions it may take you
a while to figure it out and you mind up
end up with some extra pieces you don't
know what you do with it so overall
gtm's user-friendly interface makes it a
clear winner in this category
with GTM you can spend less time
struggling with a difficult interface
and more time analyzing your data and
making informed decisions
so when it comes to pricing Google tag
manager and Google analytics have
different approaches
Google analytics has a free version
available to everyone which is good news
particularly when you just start out and
when you don't have a large budget
however there's some some limitations in
the free version and that may not be
sufficient for more complex businesses
but they can also upgrade to a premium
version of Google Analytics
on the other hand Google tag manager
offers a free version as well as a paid
version that often the paid version
offers more advanced features and
Integrations the pricing for the paid
version is based on the number of
monthly sessions your website has
so which one is better for your business
it really depends on your needs and
budgets if you're just starting out to
have a smaller website Google analytics
might be the way to go but if you have a
larger website or need more advanced
features the paid version of Google tag
manager might be worth the investment
now remember the best way to determine
which tool is right for you is to
evaluate your business needs and your
budget carefully and make the right
decisions accordingly
right so let's have a look at how you
set up Google tech manager let's dig in
and let me give you a demo of how to use
Google tag manager right so here we are
on Google tag manager and this is the
screen where you will have a list of
your accounts now here is a an empty
account I've only created tube Mark 01
and there's no tags on this there is
nothing on this so this is how you will
find your tag manager when you sign in
or sign up with your Google account yeah
so the first thing you're going to do is
to create an account and I've created
account already which is tubemark01 if
you want to create another account you
just click on create account you say
what is your account name what is the
country do you want to share data with
Google anonymously what is the container
name that could be the website right for
instance yeah but if you don't put a
container setup immediately yeah then
you just click create and then you will
have another account under this but
we're sticking for the demo purposes
with tube Mark 01 so here I'm going to
click to create a container which I
could have done as well when I created
the account but let's for Simplicity
purposes let's click here create a
container and then it's going to ask the
same questions the website is in my case
react
for russia.com
there we go and it's going to be for the
web it could be for iOS it could be for
Android for Accelerated mobile Pages or
for server-side instrumentation what
have you but the most obvious one is for
your web so you could also set tags for
your apps yep so on either iOS or
Android but let's focus on the web and
then you just click create as simple as
that and that will set you up for Google
tag manager set up for react for
russia.com in my case now here you see a
piece of code so you need to tell every
web page on your website that it is
ready to accept tags from Google tag
manager which means that there will be a
piece of code that has to be installed
on every page yeah so you paste this
code in the header and you paste this
immediately after the opening body tag
now what you will see here is that there
is still that there are the the CMS
systems to content Management Systems
like WordPress and many others as well
they have plugins that you can can get
to actually install the code for you now
you then don't actually have to install
the code but what you need to enter in
the plugin is basically this number yeah
if I click on here it takes me to that
same page of code but I don't have to do
that when I use a plugin in for instance
WordPress so I just copy and paste this
number and then Google
um will connect with WordPress and the
tag manager will be set up for the
website because otherwise of course I
would be able to put a tank on every
website out there so there need to be
some sort of a verification so you go
into the backend system of your CMS you
get a plugin for Google tag manager and
then you enter this number then
WordPress will connect with Google tag
manager create a link and then you know
read Furniture is yours and then you can
start using the tag manager now here you
see the interface it's very
straightforward you have your overview
of your tags you have the tags
themselves the triggers remember we
talked about that in the earlier
sections the variables you can create
folders and here is a list of templates
all the things that we talked about in
the in the earlier presentation here you
can have your version control and here
you have your admin where you can manage
users for instance and the admin rights
or the viewing rights yeah that they
they have so here you have if you want
to create a new tag here you see what
you are editing at the moment here you
see changes that have not been published
remember we talked about a preview mode
as well you can activate that here then
if you're happy with your tag then you
click the submit button Google tag
manager will then connect with your
website and the tags will installed so
each tag comes with triggers yeah so
because obviously the tag that you put
on the pages of your website they need
to be triggered by something that could
be a page view it could be a filling in
a form watching a video and what have
you so let's go and create a tag there
are two ways to create a tag I can go
here on new tag or I can go here on tags
yep so let's just click here create a
new tag so that takes me to the page
where I can create my tag and there is
the name of the tag that is react demo
if I can also put it in a folder and
then you will see for each tag setup
there is a configuration and there is to
trigger so the trigger is the event that
takes place when you want uh what you
when you want to trigger the the tag
coach yes so let's click here on choose
attack type and here you have a whole
library of templates of tags that have
already been created so there is for
instance the Google and analytics tag
there is the standard Universal
analytics and there is the Google
analytics 4 configuration and be aware
that by July 2023 Universal analytics
will stop tracking data so you will all
have to go to the protruder process to
set up the Google analytics 4 tag on
your website
if you don't have a template yeah I
remember you saw the template here on
the left menu on your dashboard as well
you can then just add the custom HTML
code for instance if you get a tag from
Facebook to show called Facebook pixel
for retargeting you would do that
through the custom HTML but let me first
Go and show you let's say the Google
analytics 4 configuration so very
straightforward here is the tag so I
don't have to worry about that that has
to the tag coach the only thing I need
to do is put in my Google analytics
measurement ID that is an ID that I get
in Google analytics so tag manager will
know which analytics to connect to so
let's say I'm just for demo purposes do
a random number one two three four five
six yeah so now that we've set this up
we now need to define the trigger so the
trigger is what will trigger the
tag yeah what event will trigger the
tank and there's a whole range of
triggers that you can specify for this
purpose you just want the old Pages
trigger yes so we want this code to be
installed on every page of the website
and we want to trigger the tag when
somebody views that page when somebody
then views that page it triggers the tag
the tag will connect with Google
analytics and Google will then do the
data collection of that particular page
that is as simple as it is so I click
save
and now this tag has been saved here
under react demo
as simple as that is so here I see the
tags and I now have one tag here for
Google analytics so now what I can do I
can actually preview the tag
but because I haven't connected my read
for Russia account to this particular
tag account yeah I can't show it but
when you could click on the preview it
will debug the tag as it were it will
connect with your website and then it
will test if the tag is working when
you're happy with it when it is working
you then click submit and then the tag
will be added to every page on your
website so that's basically the essence
how Google tag manager works so here you
can have an overview of the triggers and
you can create triggers yeah so I can
click the new button to create a trigger
choose a trigger type to begin the setup
and here you see a whole range of
triggers that you can use
that for a trigger setup so it could be
a page view it could be a window loaded
it could be in element visibility or a
form submission I like to scroll that so
if somebody Scrolls more than
[Music]
um
60 or 70 percent of the page that could
be a trigger when somebody watches the
YouTube video
Etc so lots of different triggers that
you can specify and add to your tag so
that is one thing the other thing that
we talked about in the presentation as
well are the variables yep so here you
see the different variables these are
the built-in variables they're available
for many of the most commonly used tag
and Trigger configurations yeah so they
can be used just like user defined
variables or you can create your new
your own user-defined variables yeah so
variable configuration that's where you
can specify URL you can have page
variables page elements or utilities so
different things that you can specify
here yeah on the variables for your
um for your for your for your tags and
for the triggers yep so and there's more
variable types in the community template
Gallery yep so those are your variables
and we already talked about the template
so that is basically all there is to
using Google tag manager so you create
an account in the account you create a
container and the container takes you to
your workspace and in the workspace you
create tags
yep and then in attack you combine a tag
with a trigger then you can test it and
when you're happy with it you click
submit and then the tag will be added to
the website now
to check if the tag has been added to
the website there is a really useful
tool that Google has available and that
is the tag assistant Legacy by Google it
is a chrome plugin and you will see in
the
um the the description of the video
below the video then simply learn will
have giving will give you the link to
download the tag assistant Legacy
basically how does that work if you go
to a website let's say simplylearn.com
what I then do I activate I enable the
Google tag assistant Legacy I'm doing
then a refresh of the page and then you
see here the tags that have been set up
on this page there is the global site
tag there is the Google analytics tag
and there is the Google tag manager and
there are some more there is a Google
ads remarketing tag which is not
operational at the moment yep so green
means there is a potential issue blue is
that it's okay red is it's not working
yes so that's what you can check for uh
for Google so really useful tool that
you can use there's also a similar tool
for Facebook if you want to check the
Facebook
tags on this page you can go and there's
the Facebook metapixel helper you will
find a link to this in the description
of the video as well and you can get it
on the Chrome Store these are free
plugins you just click on it yep and
then here you see there is the metapixel
yeah for page view for view content and
there's one pixel found on the website
yes so that is how you can do that now
how would you do the page the Facebook
pixel yeah as I mentioned earlier you go
to your workspace
yeah you're going to add a new tag
and you will see that the tag type you
don't see the Facebook pixel in here so
what you do is you go to custom HTML and
the only thing you have to do here is
paste
the
Facebook
pixel
[Music]
HTML codes
that you get on the Facebook
business manager yeah so when you set up
your advertising you can set up
retargeting and they when you set it up
properly you're getting your piece of
HTML codes and you just paste that here
okay and then when you're happy with
that you call here the Facebook
pixel
yep so you have you've pasted the code
you click save I need to select a
trigger of course yes I'm going to add a
trigger the trigger is Page views
all pages I can specify specific Pages
as well yeah and then I just click save
of course it hasn't got a code here but
now I have two tags on my
um on my workspace yep and then I can
preview it see if it works and if it
works I click submit and we're up and
running
okay that concludes the demo of Google
tag manager so let's go back to the
slides and let's close the presentation
with some tips and tricks so now that
you know how to use Google tech manager
let's close today's videos with some
tips and tricks for GT my first tip to
you is to use naming conventions yeah
they are very important and they help
keep your tags triggers and variables
organized and easy to manage
in a naming convention you should
consider the context and purpose of each
component such as the prefix indicating
the type of tag or trigger followed by a
descriptive name
a clear and consistent naming convention
streamlines to tracking and helps with
the maintenance and the scalability of
your GTM implementation
second tip I can give you is to make
sure that you test your tags before the
deployment one of the key features of GT
MST ability to test your tags
before they go live yeah you can use the
preview feature in GTM it allows you to
simulate a visitor's behavior on your
website and see how tags will fire in
real time you could also use the debug
mode to see more detailed information on
how the tags are firing and any errors
that may be occurring
it is important to test your tanks
before deployment to make sure that they
are working properly and capture the
data that you need it will help you
avoid making costly mistakes and ensure
that your data is accurate and reliable
Yeah by testing your tax before they go
live you can also identify and fix any
issues before they impact your website's
performance or user experience the next
step I can give you is to use the
preview mode
yeah Google tag managers preview mode is
a very powerful feature that allows you
to test your website tracking and tags
before publishing them
it lets you see how your tax fire how
the data is collected and that helps you
to identify issues before you go live
so with preview mode you can simulate a
firing of tax based on user interactions
and test how your tags behaved in
various scenarios
preview mode is an essential tool to
ensure that you're tracking and your
tags are working as they are supposed to
do it gives you the confidence in your
data collection and the analysis now the
next tip is the data layer functionality
in Google tag manager you're using a
data layer in Google tag manager allows
you to store and access data about your
website or app that can be used by tags
triggers and variables
it's a JavaScript object that contains
information about the user's interaction
with your website or app such as paid
views form submissions product details
and more
and by utilizing a data layer you can
simplify the implementation of various
tracking and marking marketing tools
making it easier to customize your
analytics and Advertising Solutions
it can also help you improve the
accuracy and consistency of your data
collection thereby it reduces errors and
it reduces duplications my next tip is
to use variables in Google tag manager
variables are used to define and capture
Dynamic values that are used by tags and
triggers these values can include
information like a page URL field values
click element attributes and so on by
using variables you can create more
flexible and Powerful tags and triggers
enabling you to better track and analyze
user behavior on your website or on your
app
variables can also simplify the
implementation of various marketing and
analytics solutions by allowing you to
reuse the same data across multiple tags
and triggers this can help you save time
reduce errors and making it easier to
maintain and update your tracking setup
then there is the use of folders folders
in Google tag manager are used to
organize and group tags triggers and
variables and they organize them in
logical categories
can help you better manage and navigate
large and complex tracking setups by
providing a clear and structured view of
your implementation
so by using folders you can easily find
and update specific components of your
tracking setup improving the efficiency
of your workflow and they can also help
collaborate with other teams by
providing a shared view of your tracking
implementation
this can make sure that everybody is on
the same page and follows the same
naming convention and best practices
thereby you reduce the risk of errors
and the risk of confusion so the seventh
tip is to use templates templates in
Google tag manager provide pre-built
configurations for commonly used tags
and variables making it easier to set up
and use various marketing analytics
Solutions you've seen them in the demo
they can be created by Google they're
third-party vendors or by yourself and
they can be shared across accounts and
across containers
by using templates you reduce the time
and effort needed to implement complex
tracking Solutions Airborne then you can
then focus on analyzing the data and
improving your marketing strategy they
can also help you ensure that tags and
variables are implemented correctly and
consistently
thereby reducing your error and
improving the accuracy and the
reliability of your data collection so
there's a few more tips and tricks to go
the next one make sure that you review
and audit your Google tag manager setup
it's very important that you check
regularly that your tracking tags are
firing correctly and provide accurate
relevant data for your analysis by
refueling your tracking tags your
triggers your data layer you can
identify any errors or issues
you should also check for duplicate or
unnecessary tax and ensure that your
website's performance is not being
impacted by the tax
you should also review the user
permissions and access to Google tag
manager to make sure that only
authorized users can edit or view your
tags by regularly refueling your version
history you can identify any changes or
updates made that may have affected your
tags or triggers
yes I will review and audit is essential
to ensure that your tracking data is
accurate and reliable now another one
which is very important in relation to
the
um the regular sort of audit is to make
sure that you use Version Control in
Google tag manager that's a very
powerful feature that allows you to keep
track of changes made in the containers
and easily roll back to previous
versions if necessary
so you can create a new version of the
container each time A Change Is Made
which which then can be viewed and
compared to previous versions
it helps you to collaborate more
effectively so each team member can see
what changes have been made and when
they have been made it also provides a
level of accountability and helps
prevent accidental changes that could
negatively impact your data collection
it's a very important best practice for
managing and maintaining accurate and
reliable data coming from your Google
tag manager and then finally make sure
that you stay up to date on Google tag
manager the Google tools they change
regularly they change often yeah so you
need to make sure that you know what the
latest features can offer you so follow
the official Google tag manager blog and
the Google analytics blog you can also
join the Google tag manager Community
forums there's lots of webinars about it
you can subscribe to newsletters from
digital marketing blogs and websites
that cover Google tag manager and then
of course you can follow industry
experts on social media platforms like
Twitter and Linkedin it's important to
regularly check for updates to ensure
that you are aware of new features
changes or best practices and then
there's of course also Google techman
it's just courses that you can attend
and training sessions to deepen your
understanding and knowledge of Google
tag manager
right so that's a wrap a short
introduction to Google tag manager if
you want to know more about Google tag
manager check out the various simplerone
courses Google tag manager is covered in
the various digital marketing courses if
you like the video click the like or the
share button and of course click the
Subscribe button down below if you want
to subscribe to our channel to join our
exciting Learners community on YouTube
so that's it for today thank you very
much and I'll see you at the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here